now we turn to an historic decision by
the Food and Drug Administration
approving the first over-the-counter
sale of a birth control pill any one of
reproductive age will be able to get it
without a prescription or parental
approval you'll be able to buy it in
pharmacies grocery stores and even
online Janet shamlin has more on this
change is huge change in reproductive
Health Care
the daily pill called o pill which has
been available in this country by
prescription for 50 years could be on
store shelves without a prescription by
early next year how big of a deal is
this I think it's a really big deal yeah
young women Dr Pamela Behrens is an OB
GYN and professor at UT Health Houston I
think having access to birth control is
really important for women and this is
another way to get easier access more
than three quarters of U.S women under
age 50 in a recent survey said they
wanted birth control pills available
without a prescription if teams safe and
effective they're already available over
the counter in more than 100 countries
the move was opposed by the Catholic
Medical Association the medication
should not be over the counter I think a
doctor needs to be counseling and
discussing this with patients if that's
what the patient is choosing
the approval comes amid increased focus
on birth control since last year's
overturning of Roe v Wade the FDA
reports of the more than 6 million
pregnancies in the U.S each year almost
half are unintended Opel contains the
hormone progestin and must be taken at
the same time every day to be effective
common side effects or irregular
bleeding headaches dizziness and nausea
as with many birth control pills this is
a very safe option it may not be the
perfect option for many people French
drug maker perigo hasn't announced a
price for the pills which are sold in 28
day packs but says it will make them
affordable and provide oat pill at no
cost to those who can't pay
for CBS mornings I'm Janet shamlian in
Houston